loki's been an integral villain and
eventual anti-hero in the marvel
cinematic universe for years
while he's made his mark in more obvious
ways from inside jokes to crazy comic
references
here are the best loki easter eggs in
the mcu
after seemingly falling to his doom in
thor loki reappears as a primary villain
of the avengers
or at least he seems to be he's actually
leading an invasion of earth on behalf
of thanos
laying the groundwork for avengers
infinity war six years down the road
thanos relays his messages to loki
through a hooded character called the
other
he wants to make sure loki understands
how seriously
thanos takes his mission you think
you're no
pain
while the other delivers his menacing
monologue a snake-like creature slithers
meaningfully in the background
loki doesn't need to be told twice in
the real-life collection of norse
mythological poems known as the elder
edda
the gods punish loki for killing odin's
favorite son
balder by tying him to a rock with his
own kids intestines while a snake hangs
above him
dripping venom onto his face loki's wife
sigin catches the toxins in a basin
but every once in a while she has to
leave to empty it
and the venom falls on loki's face so
painfully that he shakes the whole earth
the snake in avengers may have been a
reminder both to loki and
us of just how much pain he's endured in
the past
in the end of the avengers the heroes
save the day and capture loki so thor
can extradite him to his home in asgard
to face odin's justice as thor carries
his brother away
he's locked up not just with curves on
his wrist but a muzzle
on his mouth that seems fitting for a
character who does so much damage with
just his words
and it's even more fitting when you know
a little about your mythology
in medieval historian snorri sterluson's
younger edda
loki thinks it'd be a good idea to shave
all of stiff's hair
when the other gods catch him loki
agrees to commission the dwarves to make
sith more hair out of gold
loki offers to pay with his own head and
the dwarves get to work
making not just making a headdress for
sif but also a spear for odin and thor's
hammer mionia
when it comes time to pay loki agrees
but he reminds the dwarfs the deal is
only for his head
and if the dwarves take off any of his
neck along with it the bargain is void
the dwarves have no choice but to let
loki go but they still get back at him
by sewing his mouth shirt
to keep him from smooth talking anyone
else again
loki's muzzle in the avengers looks a
lot less painful than that
but the parallels should be clear in
thor the dark world thor and loki
commandeered one of the dark elf ships
from the asgardian impound
as thorne loki bliasgaard thor
sideswipes one of asgard's monuments
well done you just decapitated your
grandfather it's a brief throwaway line
but comics fans may recognize its deeper
significance
in 2009's thor issue 600
thor really does kill his own
grandfather thanks to loki of course
the god of mischief travels thousands of
years into the past to trap the soul of
thor's grandfather
boar in the snow then returns to
resurrect him
but not before scrambling boar's mind so
he'll attack everything in sight
as boar rampages through new york thor
finally realizes there's no way to stop
him
except by killing him all according to
loki's plan
since the penalty for killing asgardian
royalty is exile
marvel loves sneaking in easter eggs so
much that they're not content to stop
with the movies
even the tracklist to thaw the dark
world manages to squeeze in a reference
that goes back beyond loki's comic book
history
to the original norse texts composer
brian tyler includes loki's theme on the
album named lokasana
it may seem like a bunch of random
letters attached to loki's name at first
glance but it actually comes from one of
the earliest surviving references to the
character
an old norse poem collected in the elder
edda even in the middle ages the loki we
know and love was already fully formed
the poem tells of him getting kicked out
of a party
for killing another one of the guests
then returning to pick fights with other
gods
and accusing them of all kinds of crimes
finally loki politely excuses himself
when thor threatens to shut him up with
his hammer
the end of the dark world reveals that
loki didn't actually die
in his battle with the dark elves in
fact the odin that thor
has been asking permission to return to
earth is actually loki in disguise
so when thor returns from his journeys
across the universe
in search of the infinity stones in thor
ragnarok he gets to see what loki has
been up to in his absence
still pretending to be odin loki is
putting on a play that tells the story
of his supposed heroic death
with chris hemsworth's brother luke as
thor and matt damon as loki
before we see what's going on we get a
brief look at the stage itself
as thor flies over the asgardian skyline
the design fits the vanity of the whole
project
the whole thing's a gigantic recreation
of loki's own golden helmet
with its distinctive curved horns in
thor ragnarok loki's self-congratulatory
play proves that he's probably better
off sticking with super villainy than
writing
as matt damon plays loki's drawn out
death scene he used this as last words
to atone for all his regrets
including the events of the avengers and
another thing
sorry about that time i turned you into
a frog surely something that's silly
couldn't have been an actual story in
the comics
couldn't it well in the 80s writer
artist walt simonson took the reigns of
thor
with an appropriately grandiose mythic
take on the character
one full of new worlds epic battles and
poignant deaths
but he wasn't above a little change of
pace to lighten things up a bit
in thor issue 364 loki's latest power
play involves transforming his brother
into an amphibian thor doesn't let that
stand in the way of his heroism though
and he aids a colony of central park
frogs in their war against the rats
before returning to asgard thor ragnarok
takes a much more light-hearted approach
towards the apocalypse than norse
mythology does
but the film does deliver on the
destruction of asgard
toward the end of the film things look
grim for our heroes
but that's when loki shows up in a
massive ship accompanied by warriors
as as guardian refugees flee heller and
seek refuge on loki's new ship
the god of mischief welcomes him aboard
interestingly the younger edda also says
loki will arrive at ragnarok at the helm
of a ship
in norse mythology loki comes bringing
destruction
instead of salvation but thor ragnarok's
writer director
taika waititi cleverly flips the script
to suit his more sympathetic
interpretation
of the character check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorite comic
book heroes and villains are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss
a single one
you